this job try to save as many people as
we can sometimes that doesn't mean
everybody but you don't give up
New York Washington DC circle via okay
that's enough captain people are afraid
that's why I'm here
we need me put the check
whatever form that takes I'm game I'm
sorry Tony if I see a situation pointed
South can't ignore it sometimes I wish I
could sometimes I want to punch you in
your perfect teeth I know we're not
perfect
but the safest hands are still our own
god
I was wrong about you the whole world
was wrong about you they're coming for
you I'm not the one that needs to watch
their back
this doesn't have to end in a fight Tony
you just started a war
stay down fine a warning I could do this
all day
all right I've run out of patience
underoos hey everyone
you chose the wrong side
[ __ ]
do you remember me your mom's name is
Sara he used to wear newspapers in your
shoes you're a wanted man I don't do
that anymore
well the people who think you did are
coming right now they're not planning on
taking you alive
captain while a great many people see
you as a hero there are some who'd
prefer the word vigilante they've
operated with unlimited power and no
supervision that's something the world
can no longer tolerate
I know how much Bucky means you stay out
of this one please
you only make this worse you saying
you'll arrest me there will be
consequences
captain you seem a little defensive buzz
been a long day if you can accept
limitations we're no better new bad guys
that's not the last
so somebody want to punch you in your
perfect teeth
I just want to make sure we consider all
our options just people that shoot at
you usually wind up shooting at me too
you know what's about to happen
do you really want to punch your way out
of this
what do we do we fight
sorry tally you know I wouldn't do this
if I had any other choice but he's my
friend
so was I
we are feeling a hundred eyes hidden
Afghans in autonomous a [ __ ] Android's
zips to steeds